their Vanguard properties and Michael
Harris we are here today to demand that
you do not Vic Benito Santiago just me
and the other residents of this building
from his home in the divorce triangle
Michael Harrison one of the cofounders
of the realtively
is using the Ellis act to attempt to
evict him that is me in order to flip
the building and profit from his
displacement and
that's ticking away bonito has a letter
that we wanted to deliver so Santiago is
a senior and disabled Filipino resident
number of our community was born and
raised in San Francisco this greed is
tearing communities in our city apart
and we demand that it stop our homes and
communities are not for your speculation
and profit fight until the stops
we just say we just everyone we want to
be together with you you can help us out
by working together use me I have to ask
you can we order Cisco we'll make sure
he gets your message we work it out with
you no I will make sure they'll get your
message
okay
I mean I don't know I just
god bless because of the situation
brought upon by the tech industry and
gentrification in the city a lot of
activists feel this urgency working here
at the tenons union there's just people
coming in every day from for all sorts
of reasons for Ellis act eviction owner
looting evictions
every day I passed so many new
developments and they're all luxury
condos and apartments none of these
places that are being built they are for
working people that actually need
affordable housing it creates a sort of
a hierarchy of who can live in San
Francisco nothing against the techie
people coming in it's just a matter of
balancing the haves and have-nots
hopefully we all can co-exist since 1999
I've been working with the San Francisco
Unified School District as especially
ten instructor for special-needs
children when I was in school I had a
short attention span and so in order for
me to stay focused in the class my hands
will start moving now we do the same
thing already
and apparently I was upstaging the
teacher I didn't mean to I just need to
focus
it's like ended up spending most of my
time in the office you got a notice from
our landlady November 2013 that they
sold the place and then we get to notice
November 24th each one of us the three
tenants here were offered $20,000 to
leave in 30 days and we had one week to
to make a decision
my paycheck when it comes down to
cutting off all their expenses and in
taxes and all that $750 from one
paycheck bimonthly so what's that
fifteen on jet the very most compared to
four thousand you know it might be a
little slow a basic math but I know that
much that better than I should stay and
pay five hundred and seventy five
dollars rather than running hot myself
out and then leave myself to the
speculation wolves as soon as they got
word that you were gonna stay then we
were given the eviction notice I think
we're good to go
start off as pineapple boy LLC which I
thought it was a Hawaiian and then
thanks to addiction free San Francisco
find out is your name is Michael
Harrison
so I'm wondering I'd take a deep breath
and think it to myself I'm thinking
taking a deep breath as to what's gonna
happen and I know it's a big question
mark right now I'm living at home with
my parents in this Inner Sunset it was
my childhood home and so home for me you
know always felt like a safe space a
place that was really comfortable for me
and so it's been a process for me to
actually develop an idea of home that
encompasses struggles of other folks
that don't have the privilege that I do
of living in a home that my my parents
own though that edram housing rights is
something that is deeply passionate
about I just remember as a child
noticing inequality which is really
apparent in a place like San Francisco
where you can walk around and see so
many people who are homeless and you
can't sort of be oblivious to your
surroundings this right here on the
corner the corner used to be just hey
how you doing used to be a gas station
just this is recent within the last
three to five years home has sort of
become something more intense for me as
the city changes this is a New York true
play myself focus this whole block fits
me yeah this is what's happening with
gentrification in San Francisco is this
erasure of experiences in the city my
own experiences begin to fade away
fiction free San Francisco for my
experience bottom line is direct action
mobilizing people to confront these in
this case the Ellis Act speculators
Vinita is unfortunately being evicted by
Michael Harrison who's the co-founder of
Vanguard property is right around the
corner we're gonna go in we're gonna be
loud for you hub signs
we're not gonna say anything threatening
we're not gonna do anything threatening
we're just going to all demand that the
eviction be rescinded
I have an opportunity to allow the
speculators to run over me or I have an
opportunity to let the speculators know
that there's a person here that's going
to stand his ground and it's going to
call a spade a spade in that back down
what we want to declare is for mr.
Michael Harrison to rescind my eviction
especially when it comes to something
that's more of a right than a privilege
they have a roof over their head that's
a basic need
with the help of fiction free San
Francisco we went directly inside that
negative advertisement don't think they
like because a week later they says okay
why we're gonna sell the place we're
gonna you know basically tick us off
till the second solo place you know over
the course of eight months or so mmm
since when you got your eviction notice
yeah it really shows the power of direct
action and then the need for direct
action Michael Harrison didn't like the
negative PR he didn't want to give that
negative PR to bitten guard and he
didn't want to be your landlord anymore
so you just put the unit on the market
it was done so it was a it's a victory I
feel as we speak empowered empowered to
make a stand and continue to make a
stand above and beyond my status
whatever happens here
you